the acm awards the show will take place
at iconic spots
all over nashville and speaking of i'm
at the very popular pedestrian bridge
showcasing spectacular views of music
city
and just down the street at luke's 32
bridge i talked to its owner
mr luke bryant or brother uncle luke
these days
about the new addition to the american
idol family katy perry's baby girl
daisy
last time we chatted we were throwing
around uh baby gift ideas for
katie's little one daisy blimp i have
multiple gifts for this child
that require massive packaging and
boxing so
katie get ready uncle luke's got it
handled have you been able to meet her
virtually just yet
i have and i haven't actually did i
spoke to katie today i got to see my
first pictures
of that beautiful human being and i'm so
happy for them
can't wait to see her in person i'm sure
she'll be bringing her around
the the idol set american idol you'll be
doing that virtually or in person
look at you breaking the news we'll be
in person
together fair enough one big hat to
crazy
family giving lionel anxiety wow until
idol ramps back
up luke's keeping busy in nashville he's
once again nominated for entertainer of
the year
and he's prepping for his live
performance tomorrow at the acm
i had my first covet test because of the
acms
i sat down getting prepared to have a
q-tip
you know shoved to my brain you know and
my whole band and my whole crew
everybody with me had to have it done
we can't wait for you to get out there
and shake it for us and give us some one
two three four margaritas
leave it to me the party guy always
bring the party
[Music]
but we're also hearing that taylor swift
is taking the stage her first
performance in seven years
i was just like oh great just when i
thought i was gonna have the most viewed
section of the show
taylor announces nah but i'm so excited
to see her coming on the show and
obviously
um when you look at keith urban hosting
in pink i think it'll be a
great night for country music and all
music
[Music]